yeah I think that what one of the things
that will happen is that Twitter uh
parlor when Kanye buys parlor and mines
with Bill ottman's minds are going to
Federate and interoperate start to
interoperate along with Rumble Chris
pavlovsky's Rumble which is already
working with starlink to uh Interlink
their servers and starlinks networking
capabilities to get Global Internet
um and actually
solar internet like we're gonna have a
planet to plant we're gonna
interplanetary internet and you have all
these networks start to be able to
interoperate Jack Dorsey wants Twitter
to be a protocol meaning that you're
unbannable it's decentralized everybody
can post no one has control over what
you say and the only thing can happen is
if it's illegal then the police can deal
with it if Elon Musk does implement that
we know that Jack Dorsey was talking
with him behind the scenes before he
decided to buy this then there's a
strong possibility Elon does move
towards making it a protocol it does
then merge in a sense with with Minds as
a node or with Rumble gab uh um parlor
truth social even